[Music]
welcome
my name is jessica chung and i'm an
admissions officer at the
stanford graduate school of business mba
admissions office
welcome to our diversity and leadership
ask an admissions officer event
we are so excited to welcome you here
today so i'm joined by two of my
mba admissions colleagues julianne and
allison
i'll let them introduce themselves
julianne
and allison if you would like to share
your role and
how long you've been a part of the
stanford community and
that's a good icebreaker question um
your favorite place to get lunch on
campus
perhaps
well i can start my name is julianne i
am so excited to meet with all of you
today and chat
i've been at stanford for just over four
years
um with the gsb for just over two so i
am
well equipped to answer some questions
about stanford california i moved from
the east coast to california
four years ago so questions about that
i'm happy to answer
um my role i'm an assistant director and
i work
most closely with our admitted students
so i do
all of the typical responsibilities of
an admissions officer from recruiting
reading applications but my primary
focus is once you're admitted
i'll be working with you to get you
really connected with the community um
and my favorite place to eat on campus
is actually arbuckle which is the main
dining center at
the night management center so when i
was hired at the dsb i was
extra excited that i was going to be
working right across
the buildings from our buckle it's
awesome
hi everyone i'm allison happy to be with
you this morning or this afternoon
wherever you are
um i've been with the gsb for a number
of years
and have had a variety of roles in
operations and evaluation
and currently working in a marketing
role and um where we're
doing all the communications with you so
of course we love to hear how we're how
well we're doing that and um i love
coffee
total coffee snob so like a lot of
people this week probably my favorite
place
is koopa koopa cafe
awesome thank you both um and i'm
jessica i've
been in the mba admissions office for
two months and a couple days now
so i'm excited to be learning alongside
a lot of our attendees today
i'm on our outreach team so working with
prospective students
i help with our online recruitment
events
i also help manage some of our
fellowship programs
i'm super excited to be here today to
learn from the best in the business
julianne and allison
alongside with you alongside you all
today
i also want to acknowledge that we have
a number of our colleagues on the line
as well
who are greeting you who might be
helping us answer questions
in the q a box and if you
have any additional questions after this
session please feel free to reach out to
our office check out our website
we are always always always ecstatic to
talk to
prospective students such as yourselves
so please feel free to reach out to us
this session will truly be driven by
your questions
so please begin submitting your
questions for us via the q a box
we are so excited to be here really our
only
item on the agenda is to answer your
questions so please
send them our way
while i'm giving you all a moment to
start thinking about and submitting your
questions
i can go ahead and um ask a couple
of commonly asked questions to our
panelists
let me see um if i could just ask our
panelists to
give us a quick overview of our
admissions philosophy especially
holistic admissions i know that this can
be unfamiliar for a lot of our
applicants so
julian and allison if you could share
what is holistic admissions and
what does that mean for how we evaluate
mba applications
i can take a stab as the name implies
holistic admissions means we look at
everything
and as those of you who've looked at our
application you've seen there's lots of
different pieces to it
and employment and what you majored in
and extracurriculars and um there's no
formula so there's no
there's no weighting to what those uh
different aspects of of your
profile um entail and i personally
sort of like to think of it almost like
a mosaic where all these many many
different pieces
essays recommendations uh you know work
history
they're all kind of like little jewels
in this mosaic
and for each person a different you know
a different jewel
uh kind of sparkles you know brighter so
for every single
person the mix is different and um
and also everything wouldn't be um
you know exceptional because why would
you need to go to business school
if everything was already uh you know
exceptional so
so we really do look at each person um
individually
and we sort of weave the threads
together of
of the different aspects of your profile
awesome thank you i think that's so well
said i think a common misconception
about
selective admissions generally is that
people have to be perfect but
i think allison you're exactly right we
don't expect perfection nobody's perfect
um so that's really really well said
thank you and you know i would just
add i think for our international
applicants um we realized that your
educational systems are quite different
where it probably is just based on what
score
you got in the standardized national
tests and what your gpa was and so
it you know it is a much more formulaic
process so it may seem a little strange
this holistic uh process and even the
fact that we ask
essays like why would we need to ask you
to write essays to get into an academic
program
and that's really because we're not just
forming a
class of students we're we're also
forming a community here
and a lot of the learning is going to be
from each other so we actually do
care uh about who you are beyond just
your
your transcript and your standardized
test scores
absolutely feeling that you would add
no i think allison's uh covered it
beautifully i think just
said a different way we're looking at
you as the whole package so there's not
one thing
one experience one test score even that
will outweigh
all the things that you'll contribute so
it is
you know your whole story your whole
self that you'll bring and
all the things that you aspire to do
along with all the things that you've
already done
the experiences you've had so that would
be my way of just saying what allison
said in just a different
different way awesome thank you
that actually is a great segue to a
number of the questions that are coming
in the q a box
there are a lot of questions about test
scores and the gmat
a couple questions about folks who have
taken the test multiple times so could
you say a little bit
about how do we evaluate a student's
academic aptitude particularly the test
scores
and sort of how do we think about
intellectual vitality when we're
evaluating applications
i'll take a first pass at it and alison
please jump in
i think the key piece of intellectual
vitality vitality
it does go beyond your test scores and
the grades that you've earned
in your previous education it really the
heart of it is the sense of curiosity
this love of learning this desire to
continue expanding your knowledge base
and to share that knowledge with people
around you so it's that curiosity
and certainly we are an academic
institution it's a quite competitive
academic program so
your academic performance is going to be
important but it's not the end-all
be-all by any means for those who are
concerned about a test score
or gpa know that we look at both of
those components in conjunction with
each other
we know that some students you know are
not
great test takers you might have some
test anxiety you might have had
something happen to you on that day of
the test that really just
didn't exhibit your strongest
performance
which is why we also ask for all of your
transcripts
same for your academic history with your
previous degrees you may have had a year
that you know maybe something deeply
personal
took your attention away from classes in
school maybe you're working full-time or
maybe you had just a difficult
transition to
starting higher education and your
academic journey and so
all of these pieces come together we
know that
there are a myriad of factors that might
affect
a grade or a test score but that doesn't
necessarily indicate your personal
intellectual vitality so it's a
combination
of many pieces i think those two test
scores
and um your transcripts are probably the
primary place but
certainly your curiosity your love of
learning can come out in many many other
places throughout your application
um so you know don't just focus so
narrowly on
those two pieces know that we're again
looking at everything and
trying to identify different places
where you've shown
an interest and a passion for learning
and continuing to expand your own
knowledge
i would just add to that as julianne
said we look at the test scores in your
academic background
in context and so as julianne mentioned
it might
be influenced by maybe you were the
first person in your family to go to
college or maybe you
were working your way through college
that also in terms of those test scores
you know if you're um uh if you're a
history major
we're going to expect that probably that
gmat quant score
is going to be different than it would
be for maybe an electron uh electrical
engineering major
or if your first language is not english
we're certainly not going to expect the
verbal score on those tests to be the
same as it would be for a
native speaker so we do look at all all
of these
metrics you know in the context of your
particular situation
yeah absolutely and as i've been sitting
on webinars this whole week i think
i'm trying to remember who said this but
somebody was saying how
your chances of being admitted are
mathematically infinitely greater if you
apply than if you don't apply so don't
count yourself
out um i think especially if you feel as
though stanford is the right fit for you
could be the next step on your path
don't count yourself out because of
your test scores i think as julianne
said ultimately we're trying to get a
sense of
can you do the work at stanford and
there are a lot of different ways that
we think about that
beyond the test scores and i will also
add
there is a optional
and from additional information section
it is 100
optional so do not feel any pressure to
fill that out but if you have
experienced any of those
extenuating circumstances that have
affected your test scores or have
affected your gpa
or your grades feel free to use that
space to let us know
i mean ultimately we're trying to
reconstruct your experiences reconstruct
um your perspective
for our evaluation process so the more
information we have
about the context and circumstances
you've experienced the better it is for
us the easier it makes our job
so feel free to use that space if you
need it
jessica i'd also just like to emphasize
how important
academic uh that your attitude is as
well as your aptitude
you know you may be somebody who doesn't
have the highest you know gre scores
but it comes through in the
recommendations that work you're really
the thought leader you're the person who
challenges
other people's ideas and so you know
things like that that go way beyond
just you know metrics
absolutely thank you so much um so there
are a few questions about the impact of
covid
19 on the admissions process and on
the admissions and enrollment process so
can you say a little bit about how that
might be
affecting the evaluation process and
the sort of admissions numbers yeah
well i think the first thing that comes
to mind is that we haven't changed any
of our admission requirements
um we still require tests i know that in
some places across the world it might be
a little bit more challenging to get
your test scores i hope
that's been easing and getting a little
bit more accessible but certainly
if you're still facing any difficulties
please reach out to our office
we do require those tests so all of the
application
components are the same we are looking
for the same
criteria so if you've sat in on any
other sessions you may have seen that we
really
are focusing on your intellectual
vitality your demonstrated leadership
potential
and your personal qualities and
contributions and certainly you may have
had new experiences this past year that
you'll be able to add into your
application
um but for for the process itself that
has remained the same
the one piece that is different this
year is
the interviews they're all going to be
virtual at least for the
foreseeable future we don't want to risk
exposing you
or exposing any of our alumni
interviewers to
the covid 19 and certainly don't want to
put any pressure on
applicants to feel that you know some
have an in-person
interview while others have a virtual so
everything will be virtual until further
notice
and actually that has opened up many
opportunities for us to expose
applicants to a greater um proportion of
our
alumni interviewers now that we're not
bound by geography
um and so those would be i think as
those of you who are applying
just the things to keep in mind it's
very much the same as previous years
in terms of numbers um you know i think
it's
stayed relatively the same we're still
looking to admit
the same amount for the incoming class
in the future
um so i would say you know it's always
been a competitive process
uh it's still um a challenging place to
get in
but um you're sitting here you're doing
all of your research to really feel
comfortable and confident and
you know we're expecting to enroll the
same amount of students in the future
in future classes allison do you have
anything to add to that
um i i don't think so i mean there's
certainly
julianne and her team you know dealt
with
uh situations that were specific to
covid this year you know some people had
issues with getting visas and some
people were in
um covid's specific
work where they really needed to stay on
the job so i think some of those things
that were just specific to coven that
yeah yeah awesome thank you both and
i'll just quickly add we absolutely do
not want to
penalize applicants for things that are
beyond their control so i know some
folks have written to our office with
concerns about being
laid off from their jobs because of the
pandemic and the
economic fallout because of it and we
this is i think
as hopefully as clear from this panel
this is a very human process
your application is reviewed by human
beings who
i think understand the world that we
live in and
want to be your advocates in this
process so we're absolutely not in the
business of penalizing people for
things that are beyond their control
this pandemic
included and we honestly are looking for
reasons to admit you we're not trying to
find reasons to
deny you it's not that kind of approach
at all
absolutely so there are
a few questions about
um deferred admission um julian this
is probably right in your wheelhouse if
you can share with attendees first what
is deferred admission and then what does
that mean
for students who are interested in that
option sure
so i'm going to focus on the
college deferral program so this
is really intended for students who are
in your senior year or maybe you've gone
straight from undergrad
into your graduate program and you
actually don't have any
significant portion of your time working
full-time so you may have had
internships you may work part-time but
primarily you've been a student
you have the option to apply it as a
deferred
candidate which means in your last year
of your academic
program you'd apply to the gsb knowing
that you wouldn't be coming that
term you'd be coming in a future term
typically
it's a year to two years and we would
let you know which year you've been
offered and that will give you the
opportunity to work for a year or two
prior to coming to business school
get a little bit of experience under
your belt so you can feel you know ready
to contribute to the conversations in
the classroom
um i would say for for college seniors
primarily they're applying in round
three and you would
you know it's the end of your senior
year typically you
are getting ready to figure out you
might already have some job offers you
may not have a job offer yet that's okay
but this is something that you would be
considering for the future
um and i think part of your question
jessica was about you know the
evaluation and
how we might look at those candidates um
if not i'm going to assume that that's
also a question out there
um and for any any applicant not just
for those who are applying for the
deferred admission we're looking for the
same things
that intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential and personal
qualities and contributions i'm sure
we'll say it multiple times
um throughout the session but what we're
looking for remains the same regardless
of where you are in your career whether
you're a student or whether you've had
10 15 plus years of experience
however we're not assuming that somebody
who's had
you know college just work coming out of
college had a couple internships will
have had the same trajectory or impact
that someone who's you know ten years
four years five years into their career
um
same goes for if you are three or four
years into your career we're not
expecting you to have had the same
trajectory or impact yet as someone
later on their career so you're all
looked at where you are in your own um
employment trajectory
the impact that you have as a student we
might be looking more your internships
at your
what you've done maybe inside the
classroom at your university your
extracurricular impact um
we're going to still look for that those
qualities and contributions but
we may not find them in your employment
history because maybe you've only had a
three-month internship
um so if you're evaluated within the
context that you're coming from i think
allison mentioned this
in the academic piece as well the same
goes for your work history you're still
you're still um contributing in some way
and we're just finding it maybe in
different places or coming up in
different ways
i'm not sure if we said it but the
deferred enrollment
is available not just to people
graduating from college but graduate
programs as well
yes yes and i'll say that this is
separate from students who are currently
working
and applying and then might need to have
a deferral
later so we expect that you'll apply in
the year that you intend to come
we do not grant deferrals just because
it's you know you have a new promotion
or a new job that's come up and you want
to really
pursue that deferrals in that
circumstance are very rare
they really are focused on you know
required military service
um if you've had an illness and you now
need medical attention that you didn't
previously need when you're applying
maybe there's a family circumstance
that's a risen um
or perhaps you've now earned a fulbright
or you know you have the opportunity to
pursue a different
academic pursuit but that is that
deferral is very different so i think
as you're applying make sure you're
applying in the year that you intend to
come
and know that it is not um common
to be able to change that year um after
you've already been
admitted we ask you to reapply if if you
are no longer
able to come that year great thank you
both so much for those responses
sort of related well at the other end we
do have a few questions about
reapplicants as well which julianne you
mentioned
um so for students who might be applying
to the gsb
um for the second or an
or an additional time our attendees are
wondering
how do you update your application from
the prior year
is the current application compared to
your prior application
um any advice on how to navigate the
process as a reapplicant
i think would be very welcome from our
attendees yeah
i can start um we make the decision
based on your new application
and first of all you should know uh
every class has reapplicants in it so
it's it's not unusual
to to uh to get admission as a
reapplicant
some of the aspects of the application
like for example the essays
we ask you what matters most and why is
the first essay and of course that's a
pretty
profound question and so
whatever it is that matters most to you
that may not have changed
in a year or two since you applied
before but your perspective
on it may have changed with another year
or two of life and work experience so
you can certainly write about the same
subject same with the second essay why
stanford your reasons
may fundamentally be the same but your
perspective
on it may have changed so you know you
certainly want to take a fresh look at
those
in terms of the recommendations if it's
appropriate
you could certainly use the same people
you know you may have the same
uh supervisor but you would want them to
write a fresh recommendation you
certainly
it doesn't help you for them to sort of
copy and paste what they what they wrote
before
um but uh uh but as i say we we base the
decision on the your your new
application we're not sitting there you
know comparing them to what
what you previously said um i know
julian what would you add there
no i think that's very well said allison
i i
heard in will's session on the
application essay on wednesday morning
um i thought he said this very well of
you know really taking
it with fresh eyes we are looking at
your application with fresh eyes
and so um we know that some things may
not change in your application but we're
also not comparing year to year so i
encourage you who are reapplying to just
really take the time
um to start fresh and see it as a new
application alison mentioned you might
have new perspectives
and as you go through it in a new you
know really taking it from scratch
you might find that you have new
insights that you previously didn't see
or know as you're applying so
um just take it take it um seriously no
there's no you know mark against you by
reapplying
there's certainly replicants who are
admitted and
thrive at the gsp so it's certainly not
a negative to be reapplying
yeah um i would just add that um
uh i think the advantage in a way of
being reapplied
can is you can take another look at your
application with a critical eye
and um you know when we read
applications um
you know there's the applicant and
there's the application
and so often you know you may be um
you know a wonderful applicant but it
just didn't come through in the
application so
as a reapplicant you have another chance
to really look at that application and
say
you know do i really hear my voice in
these essays am i really conveying
um you know my whole self and in this
application
and just tactically you do need to start
a new application
so you can't just resubmit or update
your previous one you do need to
start fresh start from scratch um you
might be able to
pull some things and copy and paste if
you've saved it elsewhere but
fresh application from the beginning and
filling out each field individually
absolutely thank you so much for those
words of wisdom
we have a few questions coming in as
well about letters of recommendation
uh so some people have asked what makes
a great let does the position of the
recommender matter
um and how overall how should
recommenders approach those two
questions that we ask them to respond to
um so perhaps we could start with what
are those two questions that we ask
recommenders to respond to and then go
into what makes a great letter of
recommendation
so the i might not be quoting them word
for word the questions from the
recommenders but
the idea behind it is how does um
this applicant compare to other people
in similar positions or roles and then
the second
primary question we ask is can you tell
us about a time that you've given
um critical feedback or you know some
areas for improvement and
i think those are very standard
questions the recommenders will also
receive
a questionnaire that they can fill out
to kind of give some perspective on
different qualities
and skills that you might have but
really the
their time will probably be most spent
in the writing piece of the letter
um and for
i think the letters that are most
helpful are from the people that know
you best
so in that way title or position
um role in the company or institution
or even gsb affiliation if it's a gsb
alumni any of those things that you
might
think could be impressive or sway us
if that person doesn't know your work
exceptionally well and know
you in detail and can provide specific
examples about what you've done
and how you've done it those letters
if they're far removed from you are not
going to be as insightful or as helpful
for us
so my best piece of advice is to choose
people who know
your work inside and out who can speak
to not only your accomplishments but the
challenges that you faced and how you
overcame them um
those folks regardless of their title
regardless of whether or not they've
been part of the gsb community are going
to
be able to provide a much clearer
picture of
the work that you've done and will be
able to give us
more detail than maybe someone who's
further removed and that detail is
really what's
most helpful as we're trying to
understand the impact that you've had in
a variety of spaces
i think the most painful thing for us uh
when we read a recommendation is
we might read a recommender who says um
you know
julianne is the greatest person we hired
in the last five years you know
end of answer with no supporting
examples
so as julianne said you really want to
make sure that the person
knows you well enough to be able to
provide specifics
anecdotes examples details that support
their assertions
um and part of that you know is is not
just knowing you well but
actually having the willingness and the
time to recommendation like that
so another suggestion is when you're
thinking about your recommenders you
know
invite them out to coffee or tea you
know have a chat with them about
why you're going to business school and
you know if you detect
any reluctance maybe they are going to
be really busy for the next three or
four months
let them off the hook because you know
it's it's hard to turn down someone
who's asking you to write a
recommendation
but uh i think we get these one sentence
answers when maybe the recommender just
frankly didn't have time to you know to
to do it justice so you do also want to
manage your recommenders and that
in that aspect of making sure they have
the time and the willingness to
to write you uh the recommendation you
deserve right
right and i think so some some tactical
pieces of advice as well
we do ask that one of your
recommendations is from a current
supervisor um and there might be
circumstances where that's not
feasible for you you might be
self-employed you might be working for a
family member and maybe it's just not
appropriate to have your mom
write your letter for you
not appropriate um you might also be in
a situation
where by disclosing that you're
considering business school you might be
putting your employment or perhaps a
bonus or a raise or promotion at stake
and there are many people who are
applying in that situation where they
just don't want their employer to know
that they might be considering leaving
so know that that's common and no that's
okay but you do still need to think
about who else might be a good
stand-in for that current direct
supervisor so thinking about somebody
who has supervised your work so directed
what you've done or
to the best possible way so for example
if you're
you're running your own company maybe
it's a competitor
maybe it's a board member maybe it's an
investors
a client even so thinking about someone
where
they've had requested deliverables from
you
and can can provide insight into how
you've performed
those letters are much much more helpful
than say up here
who may not have insight into um
you know the overall picture of your
performance they may have just a sliver
of information about you so
thinking of who might be the next best
person along with all of the pieces of
advice
allison gave um and i think you know
her advice on just making sure they
understand what
what you're going for and why you're
applying to business school can be
really helpful in getting some
investment from them and ensuring that
they're able to spend the time
to write that letter thoroughly for you
yeah absolutely as somebody who's new to
the office
and at times i i feel like i'm an alien
who's been dropped into the process and
have had
the last few months to observe i think
julianne and allison are
are hitting all of the most relevant
points
especially about picking somebody who
knows you well
and can really provide rich
detailed vivid examples about your
impact how you solve
problems the results that you've
achieved those kinds of examples
are immensely helpful in the process so
thank you both for those very very
thoughtful answers
and i just add you know these these
letters are not long
so it sounds like you know we're asking
you to write this or you're recommended
to write this you know
tome or something but i believe the
guidance julianne correct me if i'm
wrong is
two to four pages so you know they're
not long
double spaced so it's not it's not
it's not a long it's not a lengthy piece
but it does still take time on their end
to really think thoughtfully about it
absolutely thank you both so i'm seeing
a few
questions
about work experience um i'm trying to
fold a couple questions together
um so some folks have asked about if we
have any preferences for
the type of work experience for
companies for
tenure in the in the workforce so i was
wondering if you all could
speak to how we think about work
experience and
sort of the diversity of work experience
that we welcome into our community
yeah um i think we've said it a few
times this morning that a lot of the
learning is going to be for
from each other we're trying to put
together a class with varied
perspectives and
work experiences is one of those aspects
so it will probably not surprise you to
know that
we do not expect any particular kind of
industry experience does not have to
even be any kind of business experience
i would say probably stanford maybe more
than some of our peer schools
as pro probably a larger contingent of
what you might think of
as non-traditional candidates where
we've had ballerinas in the class we've
had
farmers we've had musicians
one year i remember we actually had two
jesuit priests in the class
at the same time so uh
and so uh no particular background
um same with companies um i think
if you look at our class profile i think
we have like 420 students coming from
over 300 different organizations so
again
we love the variety of some people
coming from fortune 500 companies some
people coming from family businesses and
startups
so yeah no no preference there
awesome there are a couple questions too
about
work tenure do you have any advice for
since we've we've talked a little bit
about folks who have
um no work experience or a few years of
work experience do you have any advice
for people who are applying
perhaps a decade out of their
undergraduate experience you have more
work experience
well one thing to note if you do have
more than eight years of experience you
are also
eligible for the msx program and
i don't know if all of you are aware but
if you are considering both programs you
can use the same application
um so you're not having to submit two
different applications there's a couple
of um
differences but quite minor in in the
grand scheme of applying to stanford
um but you know i think it's really the
same
concept as we've talked about for all
different
populations regardless of where you are
in your employment experience
we're looking at those same three themes
and thinking about where you know the
impacts you've had in that
point in your career your experiences
might be different at that level maybe
you are managing people maybe you are
taking a strategic look at the direction
of your organization or your team but
maybe not some industries that's really
not
the track that's really not the way that
you're going um
so it very much varies on the um
industry you're in i'd say as well as um
the types of roles you're having so you
know
that doesn't mean though that we expect
you to have had
executive or leadership experience at
that time certainly not
but you may have and that will be very
different than somebody who's
earlier on in their career so for us
there's no preference
we really see all of your experiences as
something that will contribute and
add to the diversity of thought within
the class
um and so i think you know just apply
with confidence knowing that you
you've had an incredible journey and
story and you'll be able to contribute a
very different lens and maybe someone
who's earlier on in their career but
i think the uh benefits and gains
that you'll get from the program you
know if this is the two year program
that really makes sense
for you um are going to be just as
impactful as someone who's earlier on in
their career
yeah and again i would just emphasize
that we look at you in context so
um you as a middle manager
with 10 years of experience and some
direct reports
that's a certain kind of impact but you
may be applying as a college senior
and your impact in your summer
internship was
you know off the charts for someone in
you know summer internship at your
career stage so we're looking at impact
your uh your situation your career stage
your industry your functional area
so always always in context absolutely
thank you both so much
there are a couple questions about the
resume
component of the application um
some folks are wondering about the
format the length i believe we
say a one-page resume so if if you could
speak to
that part of the the criteria
and i'm also wondering if you could
share with our attendees
what what do you find helpful in a
resume
um what sort of information do you find
most helpful
and any other tips you can give are
applicants about how to format and
build their resume you know honestly i
don't know if you agree with me julianne
but honestly
you don't need to create a new resume
for your business school application
that's probably
the one part of the application you've
already done because you're just going
to use the resume that you would use
for um you know your work and and
obviously
you know you're going to have it most up
to date but
and if it is more than one page we
really would like you to get it down to
one page i think the one exception would
be if you do have more than 10 years of
work experience
you could have more than one page but
there's no no need to
to do any format than what you already
have
i think um just adding off of that i
completely agree allison
um but thinking about you know the
different places that you can share your
story
in the application we do ask for your
employment history and we ask for
what your role is and what your
accomplishments are so if that
we're looking at all of it so um if
that's already included
elsewhere in the application you might
choose to use some of that
space on your resume to highlight
different things that you've done so
what what i'm saying is you don't need
to repeat the information that's
on the employment history that we ask
you to fill out certainly
it should mirror the you know your
trajectory the different roles you've
had your responsibility should be
mirrored but
you have essentially now additional
lines to give some more context about
the work that you've done
if you take out maybe the two or three
lines you may have had that you put on
to
our questionnaire so think that could be
one way to think about it
i completely agree though you do not
need to make a special resume for us
um we are just interested in seeing you
know what you've done
um and and how you've made impact in
your different
roles um so take that as you will don't
put extra pressure on yourself to change
it
um but know that if you want to
highlight different things that you
could do that to you on your resume
yeah it might be helpful maybe to talk a
little bit about how we
use the resume i mean when i'm reading
an application
i'm sort of using the resume as sort of
a quick
overview so i can kind of get the big
picture and then i go to the employment
history and really dive deep because in
the employment history for those of you
who
you know looked at the application
you've got way more real estate to
describe
your specific duties and
responsibilities way more than you would
ever have on a resume
you also have some you know interesting
questions like
most significant achievement where again
you've got
a chunk of space there that you can can
write
um and so it's just a you know much more
detailed
deeper dive in the in the work history
awesome thank you both for these really
thoughtful and
sisters there's a question in here
that i think might be fun to answer what
are
some common blunders that was the word
used what are some common blunders or
mistakes that you see in the application
process
and what sort of advice you have for
avoiding those common mistakes
i bet julian you have some favorites so
why don't you go first and then i'll
add some of my favorite i mean honestly
it's just not answering the question in
full i mean it
it for as much time and um
build up there is through this
application process that i know you're
thinking about and deciding to choose to
apply to stanford or other schools
taking the test
it always surprises me when people don't
answer the question or don't answer in
full
so really read it know that some of our
questions have multiple parts
for those of you who haven't applied yet
start early
because sometimes our questions prompt
further questions as you fill them out
that may not be
visible when you're initially opening
the application and i can certainly tell
when someone was filling this out
the day before it was due and now i'm
seeing really detailed answers
at the high level and then the further
questions it's you know one line maybe
spelling errors so
um give yourself enough time fully
answer the questions
making sure that you're capturing all
parts of the question because um
for me that's i i find that very
difficult
to um
fully understand in that way just
because there is so much
invested in this process on your end so
making sure that you really are giving
yourself enough time to answer the
questions
in full um that would be my biggest
piece of advice
i've seen it time and time again and
it's not just the essay questions that
that would be and we've done the
workshops before but really making sure
we're asking you what we actually want
to know so we really do want to know
what matters most to you and why we
really do want to know
what are your job responsibilities for
this particular role
we're asking you very specifically so
don't try to
assume that we're trying to get a
different answer from you or that it's a
trick question
answer the question and answer it in
full
um allison that would be my piece what
about you
yeah i think the trick question goes to
that often
you know you might be overthinking the
question
uh when we ask what matters most to you
and why we're really asking that and i
think the common blunder i see there is
sometimes people
end up kind of writing an um mini
autobiography of themselves
and that's not actually the question the
question of what matters most to you
and why um and i think we mentioned with
the recommenders you know
sort of the one sentence answers which
again
you don't have complete control over but
i think that's part of
you know managing your your recommender
um and then i guess the the other one is
is the uh you know using an essay
from for another school and trying to
uh i'm gonna squeeze it in and make it
fit this
this this question even though it
doesn't quite fit
yeah so uh yeah yes
yeah absolutely and as i think has been
said in a number of other sessions
authenticity is so important to this
process and if you are
trying to pose as who you think we want
to read about
then i think that is also a application
a common application blunder
our goal in this process is to get to
know you not somebody who you think we
want to
admit so be authentic be true to
yourself
you are you are the person we're
interested in learning about
so um i think definitely
take that time to reflect and to
fill out your application thoughtfully
and reflect on these questions really
thoroughly
i'm so glad you said that jessica
because it's one that's i think hard to
talk about but as one of our colleagues
say
it's like only you can be the best you
that you can be
so you know you really sort of cheat
yourself
if you're trying to sort of package and
everything is so
perfect it's just not even believable
and and
and you know after reading you know tens
of thousands of these applications
we can sort of pick up if it's just
everything is it's so packaged it
doesn't seem like sort of like where's
the real person here
so um good advice yeah
absolutely and i think related to that
we have a couple questions about the
essay i know we had a couple of
fantastic
application essay workshops earlier this
week one of which was led by julianne
but i think folks are wondering
especially as they're navigating the
application processes
[Music]
about how to tell their stories device
on how applicants should pick their
essay topic especially for that infamous
what matters most to you and why essay
yeah
um i think our application workshops are
the videos are going to be posted
as well so if you did miss that that
workshop
check out the videos i think they'll be
up in about a week or so um
i i guess i would start as just saying
that the
what matters most the topic you choose
whatever it is that matters most to you
we're not sitting in judgment of that of
that topic
and so you know you may pick something
from your professional life you may pick
something from your personal life it may
be something
part of your spiritual life it may be an
idea or an ideal
that is the most important thing to you
so just don't get hung up
on what what the topic is you
truly want to pick something that is
close to your heart
resonates with you um is a good vehicle
frankly to convey to us
your influences your passions your
values and so
probably um the that kind of question
you're going to spend some time
ruminating over what that is before you
you know hit the keyboard and start
writing um because it is a pretty
pro profound question and um and i think
um uh julie and i and i have both
talked to applicants who were denied and
they said that still
that that exercise that experience of
self-examination um uh in answering this
essay
was was was very useful to them and
again
i just want to mention for international
applicants it may just seem like total
lunacy to you of like why would you need
to be answering this kind of question to
get into an academic program
but a lot um you know there's going to
be a
tremendous amount of personal and
professional growth you're going gonna
have over those two
years and so we are looking for people
who are open to
uh self-reflection and open to
challenging themselves
um and so the application is the first
step in that in terms of you
really um reflecting uh um
on on yourself
and i'll just add an addition to allison
saying we're not sitting in judgment
of the topic we are also not expecting
any particular topic so
um i think jessica part of your question
was how how do we choose what to write
about that
these are both very personal questions
including why stanford
um well that might seem
like maybe a more superficial or high
level question it actually is quite
personal because we really want to
understand
what about it specifically about
stanford's program is going to
contribute to your journey your goals
your aspirations
so beyond just being california and
beautiful weather or silicon valley
um what is it specifically about our
program that aligns with your goals
and so you do need to think about what
you ultimately want out of the gsb
what you ultimately want out of stanford
those for that for that particular essay
that is where it's most impactful is
really aligning the program
to what you ultimately want to achieve
um
and so i think just taking the time to
really be with yourself
and reflect that is going to be key
whether you're choosing
you know what matters most to you and
why or why stanford and that will be the
starting place for your writing process
um and you know high level with the
application workshop i think you can use
this for
both essays but really just continuing
to
dig deep into why um just posing that
question to yourself over and over again
to really you know
uncover all these different layers of
either what matters most to you
or why stanford and that should give you
a really good writing process to kind of
get to the heart
present your authentic self and still
being honest throughout the application
process
absolutely thank you both so much yeah
can i add one more thing jessica again
i'm thinking of international applicants
who might be
worrying a little bit about like does
this app does this essay have to be so
perfect because
english is my second language and again
you're not applying to
you know an english master's degree or a
creative writing program this is a
business school program
so we're really focused on the content
we're not
concerning ourselves about you know
syntax errors or anything like that i
mean of course you're going to run spell
check on your essay
but please don't be concerned at all
about
uh you know writing style or
grammatical mistakes or things like that
we're focused you know totally
um on on the content
awesome thank you both so much my
favorite proofreading tip so i used to
work in undergraduate admissions
so this might feel sort of basic but i
always
would recommend reading your s
stay out loud number one because it
helps with reading because i think it
can really help with
checking to make sure your essay sounds
like you like if you're writing
something that doesn't sound like you
you can really tell when you
read it out loud in your voice so that
would be
one of my concrete tips for approaching
the essay
there's a great question in here about
how much clarity applicants should have
about
their job goals or their post mba plans
that's a good one yeah that sort of goes
along with the why stanford
essay doesn't it people worry about that
in that why stanford asked me they have
to have their whole
life figured out their whole career
figured out
and that's not not true at all we know
that you're coming here to explore and
in fact the vast majority of our
students are going to change
careers in some aspect of functional
area or geography or industry or
something
but we do want you to help us understand
how you're going to use the stanford
experience to help you explore
and it may be exploring um you know
particular industry
it may be a hypothesis about yourself
that you
want to test while you're here so
it could really be anything and the
reason we
do want to know that you have spent some
time thinking about this
is when you come to stanford i mean
you're like in this huge
you know confectionary shop where
there's just
hundreds of courses you can take in fact
across the entire university and
extracurriculars and you know there's
there's so much here and there's
there's no way you could do it all and
so at least having some kind of filter
for yourself
in terms of being able to filter and a
lens to make choices
of like how are you going to know what
you know classes you want to take
outside the business school unless you
have some sense of
of uh of what you're exploring here
awesome thank you so i think we have
time for maybe one or two more questions
there are a couple of really great
questions in the q a box about
past past career pivots so some folks
might be coming to gsb
to pivot and there are some folks who
have
pivoted once twice multiple times before
applying so do you have any advice
for applicants about how to explain past
career pivots
how to frame those experiences anything
anything related to to pivoting your
career prior to business school
well within our um application form
itself
when we're asking you to fill out your
employment history we also ask the
reason why you left
each role so that would be a really good
place i think to
um provide a sentence or two about what
ultimately
you know propelled you to change careers
um it's not a ton of space but actually
it's quite effective and seeing like
you know i moved from investment making
because i wanted to have a greater
impact
in my community something you know it
can you can
pretty much give us the the high level
reason for why
and we don't need to know more detail
than that because we'll then go on to
see the impact that you've had and
how you've built upon the skills that
you've acquired
we know that not every career is linear
many careers you know
spiral and pivot and turn and so it's
very normal
um we're not you know questioning like
wow this looks this looks strange why
did they move from this to that that's
not it
we do want to understand why and maybe
what um
what gave you that ultimate boost or
that that sparked that interest in that
new career for you
um we also expect that you'll probably
change directions after business school
or once you're here we're not going to
be
holding you to what you said you want to
do in your application when you graduate
we know that you're going to be filled
with different opportunities
and options to explore so
just if there's if there is a situation
where you really want to give more
context i think the additional
information could be a great place
and you might be able to find places to
work that change in maybe in the
optional impact
questions it may come up in some of your
essays but it doesn't have to
um so there are a couple places but
really for me i think
you know one or two sentences and why
you left that role is sufficient for
for the vast majority of changes
absolutely i keep i'm coming back to
what allison said at the beginning
of the session which is we don't expect
you to be a
perfectly finished polished product in
your application
if if you had already achieved
everything there was to achieve
why would you apply to business school
so
i think yeah absolutely
we understand that life happens your
values and your goals change and shift
and evolve so
um yeah i think i think you both have
hit it on the head
and i think we have i think most of us
would agree that
you often learn more from your
quote-unquote failures than from your
successes
yeah absolutely i think a panelist
in a session i went to earlier this week
said
sometimes you win and sometimes you
learn and i love that
i want to get it tattooed on my forehead
so next time you see me on one of these
webinars it might be on my forehead
um let me see
i think we've we've hit a lot of the big
questions that have come
in i know we only have a few minutes
left
so we are going to launch a poll for our
attendees
we would really love to know how your
experience has been in the session
it's been sort of a novel year for us
doing all of this online so if you could
please
submit your feedback we would really
really appreciate it
and i'm wondering from our panelists if
you have any
last few words of advice anything that
we haven't covered that you think
applicants should know
about this process
i guess i would just say you know
there's so much information
and misinformation and myths out there
and
you can sort of drive yourself crazy
trying to
follow everyone else's advice so
i would just say in this process to the
best that you can sort of put blinders
on
block out all the urban myths and
and just focus on yourself and the
process
um and you'll you'll be fine
yeah i completely echo what allison said
just you know
take a breath be confident we really are
looking to understand your
accomplishments and how you've
approached challenges and
really to get to know you so um we're
excited
to get to know more about you as you
apply we're looking for reasons to admit
you not to deny you and we're just
really
interested in hearing about all of the
amazing things and contributions you've
had into your different spaces
so um just be confident be excited this
is a chance for you to tell your story
in a way that that's empowering to you
and we can't wait to get to meet you one
day here hear your stories
yeah we're in this line of work because
we're truly
excited and we love getting to know you
through your application so we sincerely
look forward to
reading reading about you absolutely
and i think we all know that this
process can be
very anxiety inducing but also know that
this is not a process you have to go
through alone
um you have i i think
part of this process is finding those
mentors and allies and advocates who are
in your corner willing to write that
letter of recommendation
willing to proofread your essay um
willing to practice interviewing with
you so draw on those people in your life
who are in your corner and we're in your
corner too
if you have any additional questions
please feel free to reach out to our
office we are in your corner we
give this advice for free um so know
that you can always reach out to our
office
if you have any any remaining questions
so with that thank you all so much for
joining us today thank a huge thank you
to my colleagues as well for your
thoughtful responses to
our attendees questions and you can
continue your journey at mystanford.mba
and learn more about the events we offer
life at stanford gsb
and continue to connect with us so thank
you all so much for being here and have
a great rest of your day
thank you thank you take care bye